hello everybody welcome back to css3 in  30 days  today is a unique lesson and we won't  actually be doing any coding within the  video however I encourage you to play  around with what you're about to learn  after the fact we css3 ninjas like to  push the boundaries of web design which  means that we get to dance on the  bleeding edge of supported code  unfortunately everyday ordinary browsing  citizens and their old and outdated  browser software may not be as fresh as  us P or not there's a css3 rule that  recognizes the downfalls of everyday  ordinary browsing citizens rectifies the  problem and leaves the user blissfully  unaware of our epicness it's simple  really  just use the app supports rule and pass  in a CSS property value pair to test  whether or not the browser recognizes it  like so  now if the browser understands it will  render the code between the curly braces  otherwise it will move on like a chump  [Music]